[Music]
thank you everyone for coming I see a
few more people showing up that's great
my name's Andrew Phillips I'm a product
manager in GCP DevOps that's the part of
Google cloud that worries about like
local developer and software delivery
tooling and and I want to be kind of
really quick and efficient with my part
of this presentation because I really
want to tee up John over there who's
going to introduce himself John angleman
from Target who's going to talk about a
really fascinating journey about
building and why and how and lessons
learned an application delivery platform
I'd like to kick it off a little bit
though just by way of introduction for
setting the kind of stage for white
actually makes sense to think about this
as a separate problem in the first place
especially in an enterprise context and
some of the lessons that we from a
Google perspective can share in that
area we just said that all right
blah the me slide I mean from a
background perspective I've been in the
space for a really long time I've been
both a developer and the head of duck
tape aka head of operations and a
product manager and all these kind of
things so I've seen lots of pain from
lots of different angles here one of the
things I did a lot of when I was a head
of strategy in this space was I showed a
slide like this every enterprise must
have seen this slide 50 million times
it's the classic slide that says if you
don't find a way to speed up you are
going to go bankrupt and there's lots of
good data to back this up and so it's a
really genuine problem and thus I think
it's legitimate that we all think about
it but by and large people are convinced
that this is genuinely an issue to look
at and what then tends to happen and
this is I think where an important
lesson comes in is that you start
drawing a diagram like this right my
software delivery pipeline source code
over here just a few things I need to do
and then I'm going to be in production
it kind of looks sorta simple and
compelling and you could imagine if you
have a simple website with some code but
I could sort of work but of course the
reality first of all is that it's
actually more of a tooling a landscape
that looks a little bit like this and so
it's an enormous integration game that
you already start to have to play and if
you try to play that integration game
all across the pipeline in one go
it's very quickly a boil the ocean type
problem and I think we all know how this
goes wrong and and there's just too much
to tackle to get this right so I think
an important lesson to start out with is
that not just is there you know there's
a big challenge lying under this
deceptively simple diagram but I think
there's another really important point
and that is conceptually thinking of it
as this just go back one does this work
can I go back thinking of it as this
conceptually simple left-to-right just
do all the things diagram obscures the
fact that there's actually two related
but different processes at work here and
so the way I draw this diagram now is a
little bit more like this I don't really
use the term CIN CD very much because
they kind of imply automation and more
automation instead I talk about the
developer feedback cycle and the
application release cycle on the other
side and I find that framing helps me a
lot because a you know if you look at
what we do is Google or what many other
companies do your developer feedback
cycle you want that to run every single
time you propose or commit a code change
and if any of you heard the cloud build
announcement I'm sure a lot of you did
Google's doing a lot in this space to
provide great tooling to make that
really easy and really efficient and
this is all about speed and efficiency
and getting great information back to
your developers as quickly as possible
but then on the other side you have the
application release cycle which maybe
you want to do every time you commit a
line of code or maybe not maybe you do
it weekly or every sprint or whatever
and here there are many different
triggers and the goals are also somewhat
different you're typically not worried
all that much about doing this as fast
as possible you're worried about doing
it in a compliant way in
that prevents risk from creating
problems for your organization etc etc
etc safe compliance all these kind of
adjectives come into play and if i zoom
in a little bit more specifically on
that second half of this pipeline
application release what are actually
three components from my perspective or
from our perspective that have really
important to think about here very often
if you think of it as a pure automation
problem you only really think about the
middle one application deployment which
is those steps that you need to take to
get your bits and bytes actually into
production but there's two other very
important parts that we see a lot of
people recognizing at large scale one is
the simple notion of how do I even
understand what is running where that's
not a process problem that's a problem
of understanding your current state and
sure if you have a single run time in a
single GCP project that's not a big deal
but if you're doing multi cluster
multi-cloud maybe different types of run
times it starts to become a huge problem
and not only do you want to understand
what's actually out there you probably
also want to act on it in certain
limited ways you want to roll back you
want to scale up you want to scale down
you want to understand health and so on
and then another aspect of the
deployment process specifically or the
application release process is that
there's a bunch of kind of
domain-specific best practices that are
really important to implement in this
area and that ideally you would like
tooling in this space to give you
out-of-the-box whether it's things like
immutable infrastructure or good support
for roll backs or canary analysis or all
these other kind of things like
everything else they can all be scripted
but it's much much better if you can
provide this functionality out of the
box I'm not going to go through all of
them and then obviously from a
perspective of what we know enterprises
want and indeed most developers and
operations teams want great to have all
this functionality but we wanted to be
secure we ideally wanted to be open so
it's extensible and understandable we
would like hybrid and multi cloud
support and we wanted to support all the
other 50 thousand things you remember
from that slide I showed the little
earlier because of course we can't throw
away everything we have we need to
leverage our existing investments etc
etc etc so this is me teeing up
spinnaker here effectively this is an
open source project which was originally
conceived well the predecessor version
actually was conceived as Netflix's
continuous delivery platform for this
part of their lifecycle and it's now a
very successful open source project used
by John we'll talk about how target uses
it but used by Netflix and Google and
many many other companies obviously
supports all the runtimes that we care
about kubernetes big topic here but all
the other ones that we know across
multiple clouds and there's a lot of
people using it I won't bore you with a
logo slide it's a nice one to look at
later going back to the four key
attributes that I talked about one of
them was open and we find that very
important for our customers not just
because it gives them flexibility in
where and how they run it but also
because it gives companies release and
platform engineering teams the
capability to tailor it to their needs
and to match the requirements that every
company comes up against and that is
somewhat different in their contexts so
with that let me hand it over to John
who will talk about exactly how targets
solve this problem afternoon everyone
I'm very excited to be up here talking
about targets journey in this path
t-today my name is john Engelmann I'm a
principal engineer with the release and
run time engineering group at Target and
I basically do what what Andrew does as
well but for target I'm also a regular
open source contributor I've been
working in in kind of the build
automation and deployment and cloud
spaces for a number of years now and I
prior to coming to Target I was working
as a consultant and doing this for
everything from 10 person companies up
to today where I'm doing it for a
fortune 50 company in a number of
different different spaces so before I
get into how target does this today I
want to give you a little bit of idea
and I want to reinforce some some of
what Andrew was saying just a little bit
so first of all from my
experience as a consultant this is this
journey is not unique to target this is
the same path that I've seen many many
companies go on I'm also not gonna stand
here and tell you the answer to this
problem right because there isn't one
answer I find that building platforms
and in particularly this application
delivery space there's not a single
solution because the solutions have to
be geared for your particular business
and technical requirements right it's
almost a very personal engineering
problem space they have happened also
just just you know simply everything
Andrew said is right when we started
putting this talk together it was it was
very interesting how quickly our ideas
coalesced around the same things one of
the issues that I see in the industry
right now is that we have a tendency to
refer to see ICD as like a singular
composite concept right I have a see ICD
tool I'm doing see ICD etc but as Andrew
was saying it's it's very they are
separate right so continuous integration
is about modeling that software
development cycle how developers are
getting feedback how are we increasing
velocity and an increase in the quality
quality of our code by decreasing that
cycle time right and ultimately the
outcome of that cycle is that we're
producing a deployable artifact that we
consider good based on the information
that we have today so one of the things
that we strive for is to get this this
automated code coverage that covers
everything and if anyone says that
they're aiming and striving for a
hundred percent test coverage that
that's great and we should do that but
it's absolutely not required to be
successful at a continuous integration
right and on the other side continuous
deployment is about that software
delivery cycle right and and here the
real purpose is to decrease the impact
to customers of disruptive operational
actions that we're taking on our
application right in our and our outcome
is to make available a new version of
our software and be able to recover from
any possible regressions that happen
during that
during that deployment so in this sense
both of these actions are orchestrated
workflows but with very different
requirements right and if you look at it
a CI workflow is very linear in general
where if an error occurs along that line
we basically say stop right just just
stop fail out don't do anything more and
then they can be they're generally very
short running
whereas in continuous delivery we have
this very complex logic of what to do
when we're rolling out right there's
external forces acting that are that are
telling us what to do next and in a
failure case how do we recover from that
and these continuous delivery workflows
can be very long running anywhere from
minutes to hours to days or even longer
depending on what type of system we're
rolling out so to summarize that CIN CD
really are two disparate ideas and and
we and it doesn't imply that we're using
a single tool to solve them if you have
a single tool that solves both those
problems and it works for you that's
great but we don't have to so so target
and and how are we solving some of these
problems so before I tell you what we're
doing today and what we're gonna be
doing tomorrow I got to tell you where
we came from and what we were doing
yesterday so let's rewind the clock five
years so long before I joined target and
we were a traditional enterprise
organization right we had we had
development teams we had operations
teams and developers built Co code and
through that over the wall to operations
teams that deployed it and monitored it
and managed it there so very traditional
workflow in that sense our delivery
cycles were tied to business and
financial calendars and and all that
stuff and I think any time that you look
at a state of a system or or a process
or an organization you have to there are
pros and cons to both those things right
so one of the pros for for this kind of
traditional enterprise even though most
of us would say there's nothing pro
about it is that we did have decoupled
development and delivery cycles now they
it wasn't a great decoupling because we
ended up in these large you know big
paying deliveries with intensive
integration cycles and things like that
and we also got into that siloing of
responsibilities right and and when
everyone thinks someone else is
responsible ultimately no one ends up
being responsible and that's really
coming back to the TLDR is just that we
weren't doing devops yet and this is a
very common starting point for many many
enterprises or large organizations so we
knew we needed the change and and our
developers actually kind of took that
into their hand and started to
organically grow the usage of chef as a
configuration automation tool within
target this allowed them to reliably
provision new servers in a very
consistent manner we were dropping our
times of how long it took to get a
server out there and running but very
very quickly from potentially weeks to
hours
right so we started introducing some
commonality through our processes we're
able to write some higher order tests
and functions we started sharing
knowledge among our development teams
about it you know what are the best
practices for really doing this but on
the other side we we went from this
decoupled cycle into now and you know a
process where we were conflating runtime
configuration with with application
versions and epicly application delivery
we were still you know we're obviously
still using mutable infrastructure so
things like rollback were very difficult
um and because it grew organically and
naturally out of dev teams there was no
real guidance right so we started seeing
some some anti patterns developing
within the tooling and implementation
that we had so we knew we needed to
provide some structure for our
developers and users to to encode these
best practices and one of those is that
we shouldn't use a configuration
management tool as a general-purpose
Orchestrator right if we're just trying
to automate you know fluid tasks there's
probably better tools situated for that
for that purpose and finally we knew we
needed to we needed to model the actual
deployment from the ground up and not
just the runtime of the application so
after about a year of working for the
shop with chef in the organization we
started building a new intern
called Houston and Houston was an
infrastructure management tool so it was
built around our native infrastructure
provider api's it used their tooling it
still used chef underneath the hood
to provide runtime configuration and it
again it it gave us a step to to more
closely model and automate more of
what's needed to get an application out
out and running and it further reduced
that time so we started introducing
concepts such as infrastructure as code
deployment strategies to our development
teams we further reduce that time but on
the other side we we created a homegrown
tool that offered no support out in the
greater community when our devs had an
issue they couldn't go to Stack Overflow
or google and find the answer to the
problem we couldn't source any any work
or additions to the tool from outside of
Target let out and not even from inside
target because it was so the code was so
custom that just the team that built it
was able to support it and the biggest
mistake that we made in in Houston was
that we introduced our own language -
what an application deployment was we it
had this idea of missions and orbits and
things like that what we've learned from
that is that we had built this tool
strictly from the vision of how are we
going to automate and make
infrastructure development easier and
better right and that doesn't always
work for developers right so we had this
impedance impedance mismatch right we
had built a tool that was really really
good at infrastructure mated
infrastructure but not so good at
modeling an application itself and we
also learned that we just shouldn't try
to create models and abstractions that
that don't convey what it is right you
had you have to talk about your
application deployments in a way that
that is linked to the practical concepts
and features that they're represent
right so we don't call a dog in orange
because it's a dog not an orange right
so we should call a server a server or
an application and application
so after about a year working with
Hewson one of our one of our engineers
came in and said hey you know I've been
playing around with this tool out of
Netflix called spinnaker to do those
some things and I think it would help
solve a lot of problems for us and I'm
not going to get into all the deep down
nitty-gritty about spinnaker there's
lots of resources out there but
ultimately fundamentally spinnaker is an
immutable infrastructure tool right it's
built around those concepts of
immutability and this was a very seismic
ship for our developers and our
infrastructure to start thinking about
we had to rethink many many parts of our
platform right we had to rethink how we
were getting runtime configuration and
secrets we had to rethink how we were
packaging applications so we needed to
start small because there were gonna be
a lot of moving parts and and a lot of
things that we needed to change and fix
so so we started with a small pilot
group of dev teams that we knew could
could move and make changes as we found
out and learned lessons and things like
that and as we started rolling this out
and working with these pilot teams we we
learned a lot about spinnaker right
because no one had the experience with
it yet but we knew that Spinnaker's
pipelines were were very robust at
modeling how we wanted to roll
applications out to places it gives you
just about anything you need
out-of-the-box to do that but we didn't
use all of it all the time most of our
development teams just simply need to
get an application out right it's a
stateless application they need to bring
up a new server group they need to get
traffic to it and they need to shut down
the old one right so while spinnaker has
lots of ability to model complex
workflows we didn't necessarily need it
all out of the gate where we did need
where we did need it was to support our
infrastructure teams so things that
weren't stateless applications
elasticsearch kafka Cassandra things
like this where we needed a much more
refined control and how we were
deploying large clusters of things and
spinnaker allowed us to do that so not
only did it solve the simple problem for
us it also allowed us to solve the
difficult problems as well
so we we did this pilot we started
seeing you know we were able to get
better visibility into our deployment
footprints we were getting better
consistency but our dev teams were
starting to tell us you know you're
abstracting us too far away from the
infrastructure we we want we want to be
on the native right right on the API and
things like that and the biggest
frustration that they gave us is you
know it's three years and you're giving
us a third platform right so three years
in a row we've we've asked them to
change so they were getting a little bit
of frustrated on that so we had to stop
and ask ourselves okay do we do this do
we push this across the whole
organization was there enough value in
doing it and unsurprisingly yes if I if
the answer to this was no would be a
very anti-climatic talk right so so if
we look at the cost value of what
spinnaker brought us at the end was this
real this simplification of the
infrastructure so the primitives that
spinnaker uses I'll talk about
applications such as server groups and
clusters all right you know model any
type of application delivery really
really well and then on top of that it
uses a naming base pattern to correlate
an aggregate infrastructure so you get
kind of an application graph of what
belongs to an application it also this
has a really really good workflow
orchestration engine and if you've ever
implemented a workflow engine of any
kind you know that they're hard
so Spinnaker's engine is is it's very
scalable it supports resuming and air
conditions or even restarts of it it's
flexible it's fast and and companies
like Google and Netflix are using it to
drive you know giant giant deployments
across their organizations so we know
it's battle-tested and it and it works
well and finally if you heard our CIO at
the keynote yesterday morning
target wants you know target has wants
to support open source communities as
much as possible we leverage a lot of
open source technology we want to
contribute back to that
so spinnaker as an open-source tool with
backings of many companies big and small
you know it was a great place for us to
get into that to that community so we
could leverage their knowledge we could
we could give back we could participate
in that whole thing so we've decided to
move onto spinnaker at this point and we
got it and we have to figure out how do
we move spinnaker out into the rest of
target right the first start is the
first hand the first part is we needed
to add support for targets private data
centers so spinnaker ships with a number
of cloud provider implementations but
not all of the ones that we use in our
infrastructure were supported so we put
together a development team and we
joined them up in the spinnaker
community and they were highly active
they collaborated with some other teams
and they started contributing back major
implementations of Spinnaker's
underlying code to support our
infrastructure we also had to roll out
additional integration with other
platforms that we have such as
kubernetes and things like that
in order to facilitate this internally
we started organizing flash builds
between development teams and our
platform engineers to kind of sit with
them and be an embedded with them and
move them on to these platforms because
they were moving from these some of them
were moving from you know n minus 2
platforms from chef into this and let
alone from the previous platform from
Houston so in the end targets topology
looks something like this within within
our kind of our private data center and
public cloud we use OpenStack for VM
deployments we use kubernetes and our
data center we use Google cloud platform
out on the edge we use other providers
on top of that as well so we're using
quite a few of the components inside of
spinnaker at any given time and one of
the things we learned is we probably
should have stopped and rewound and
thought about how we were doing things
because we you need to think about how
you're going to be onboarding users and
applications into spinnaker because it's
based on this static name because it's
based on a naming convention and because
you're dealing with immutable
infrastructure
if you don't adhere to those patterns
right out of the gate you get into a
position where you're having to move a
lot of things later in order to make a
better organization if you're looking at
running spinnaker at scale you also need
to to understand how Spinnaker's
configuration works what the different
micro service components do and how
you're going to manage that
configuration and rollout changes to
your users because if you're giving your
developers direct access onto spinnaker
you don't want to be bringing it down
for them right because they can't be
they can't run their deployments or
manage their applications and finally
you need to understand exactly how the
different provider implementations and
spinnaker that you're going to be using
actually interface with those downstream
providers because this is going to
greatly impact how you can scale and
manage performance of spinnaker itself
so so here's where we're going to
deviate into kind of a quick expert
section of spinnaker so as it did is
anyone here running spinnaker at their
companies all right so some so scaling
concerns as you start bringing spinnaker
up if you're talking about you know you
know something like targets scale not
all provider implementations and
spinnaker are built the same so you can
easily run into problems where depending
on the implementation you could run into
things like API rate limit problems or
even overloading the downstream provider
api's right so you want to look at how
you're tuning some of those polling
intervals if you can do caching of api's
and things like that the AWS
implementation and spinnaker has
something called etta that lets you
cache API calls also make sure you have
enough memory to run things because it
because spinnaker is collecting data
about your infrastructure it has to
collect this the current state of all
your deployments in order before it can
flush it into its into its cache to do
queries so you need to have that kind of
that room to get data as you're scaling
out and finally by default spinnaker
uses Redis as a caching agent for most
of its components and Redis a
single-threaded
so at anytime only one thing can be
reading and writing from Redis what you
can do though is make every spinnaker
component use a different reticences and
Redis instances are cheap most any cloud
provider you're gonna be using has
managed Redis or something compatible
and just from day one just deploy a
reticent sense for for each thing don't
don't fall into the trap of using a
single Redis it also has some more
advanced concepts where you can manage
charting mechanisms inside of read it
instead of spinnaker itself by
application or origin or user so that
you can scale different parts of the
components component reef so spinnaker
deployment at target looks something
like this there's a component inside of
spinnaker that's called cloud driver
that's responsible for talking to the
downstream provider api's and we run
those in both a read a read write and a
read-only mode so we have one fleet of
cloud drivers that can make the mutate
operations into our infrastructure and
we have another fleet that is just
purely responsible for gathering the
current state of that infrastructure
back those cloud driver implementations
talk to fleets of read/write reticences
that are replicating their data to read
only instances of Redis so we can manage
that and in between the two we actually
run in an open source application called
2/m proxy that allows us to shard data
across multiple reticent senses so we
can kind of get that feel of a
multi-threaded reticent sense even
though it's single threaded and this
whole thing is automated and configured
in such a way that if we even need to
bring up a whole new spinnaker
installation in order to support
something we can do that at at
effectively the the press of a button so
in the end we ended up with a with a
topology or an insulation of spinnaker
that has multiple scaling dimensions
right we can scale everywhere from the
cache up to the individual spinnaker
components and and then spinnaker
installations themselves and we can
adjust the right knob for whatever
performance problem we're seeing or or
if we've just sudden the increased load
or scale on something
and this this ended up being a really
good a really good process for us
because we did run into situations where
before we had this topology we would we
would run into some type of scale
induced thing and we we wouldn't be able
to adjust correctly so that so that's
where we are in our in our private data
center in our in our public cloud usage
right now most of our app teams are
using spinnaker to deploy to VM based
workloads
some of them are using spinnaker to
deploy to kubernetes space workloads but
we are starting to see a little bit of a
divergence here where a lot of app teams
just want to if they're on kubernetes
they just want to talk kubernetes right
they want to use cube CTL they want to
use helm they want to go straight to
that cluster and they want to use native
kubernetes capabilities across there so
so we've gotten a bit of a divergence
there happening and as we talk about
kubernetes I'd be remiss if I didn't
talk about targets sores so not only do
we have private data center in public
cloud but target has 1,800 stores across
the 50 in across the United States and
in each one of these stores and
distribution centers we run our
kubernetes cluster so but because of the
distribution of the of these stores and
these and these distribution centers and
the connectivity that we have with them
we have to treat them as though they're
completely isolated cloud environments
from our perspective we can't be back
hauling data from them all the way back
to Minneapolis all the time right so
effectively we have 1,800 cloud
providers that we have to deal with at
any given time so how do we manage this
how do we manage rolling software out to
1,800 disparate clouds so the first
thing that we do is we group our stores
into into kind of groupings and
environments based on things like
geography or size of the store or you
know features or technology that we have
installed in them and things like that
so these environments can consist of
anywhere from one store to 300 stores
and when we push new software loads out
to the stores we roll them out to these
environments and in a sort of batch type
fashion right so
if I push to an environment that has 50
stories and in all 50 stores are gonna
get that same software load and be
running it if I'm gonna roll that back
all 50 of those stores are all back that
software so how does spinnaker
understand this kind of you know weird
grouping thing that we're doing with all
these with all these stores if if you
you probably haven't read the target
blog but if you had we recently posted a
thing and it's called you know matrix so
you know matrix is a tool that we built
in-house to manage our Star deployments
and it effectively is a spinach is a
kubernetes api facade layer so it
presents a urban at ease compliant api
replica sets and pods services config
Maps the whole spiel and it presents
those store groupings as namespaces onto
that API so we point our spinnaker
instance at the you know matrix server
running in our data center and it
distributes desired State out to each of
the stores in that namespace and the you
know main the you know matrix agent
there that applies that state to the
local kubernetes cluster and is
responsible for recovering status and
sending it back to us
so from Spinnaker's point of view we
have one kubernetes cluster running for
all 1,800 stores and this allows us to
reason about very large scale
deployments in very simple terms for
both our developers and any operations
and support staff that we have to deal
with it helps us eliminate deployment
drift across these store environments
and we're adhering and utilizing an open
source API specification which means any
of the tooling out there that's built
against kubernetes api we can continue
to use against our store deployments
even though we have 1800 of them behind
the scenes so what we learned from from
running you know matrix we've been
running this for a while now in our
store deployments and we've learned that
abstracting the infrastructure is good
right it allows us to reduce that
complexity and make better decisions
about what should be done that doesn't
mean our developers shouldn't interact
directly
with that API many of our source
developers still use coop CTL to talk to
you new matrix in order to perform
operations in the stores environments we
also needed to start thinking about what
what really is an application or
deployment right and so you know matrix
helps us distill that those input that
concepts down to what should be running
how is it configured what's its current
state things like that and it also kind
of taught us that you know this
micro-service thing is really really
good because we can just replace pieces
of of component tree where we see fit
with our opinions or patterns or
optimizations that work for us so that's
our current state today at Target and
about six months ago we started working
on a new a new project because our
current state is one where we still have
many different ways of doing things
right we're still talking to some
kubernetes clusters directly we're using
spinnaker in places we're using you know
matrix for stores etc right and we
really want to get to this paradigm of
there should just be one way of writing
and running and deploying an application
at target and the way that we think
about it is the idea of a midnight
developer in Dan woods our distinguished
engineer had a good point had a really
good statement of this as a developer at
target has to be able to build an
application in the middle of the night
without having to interact with anyone
with no previous knowledge of our
platform if they can't do that then
we've failed as an engineering and as a
platform organization right and so
that's really kind of the guidance of
what we've been trying to do over the
last six months and so there's kind of
six main points of how how we're
designing and building that platform so
first we have to have a self-service
platform right our developers can't be
sending emails or issuing pull requests
or or doing things I'm waiting for
people to get back to them a day later
we have to have a common pattern of
usability right regardless of where
they're running on the infrastructure
they need to be right be able to write
that application one time they need to
be able to discover the features of that
platform it needs to be highly available
so that they can do their job
and the way that we can do that is
through applying some strong opinions
but still allowing for flexibility
within the infrastructure and the
platform itself and finally as as
platform engineers we need to treat
everything as an application we if we're
gonna be asking our developers to follow
these processes or use these opinions or
run on this platform then we better be
too so we so over the last six months
we've been building uh we've been
building a new platform called target
application platform or tap and it's
really it's combining the best pieces of
all the different tools and all the
different infrastructures that we've
dealt with over the last five years as
we've come along on this journey we're
combining the power of kubernetes
declarative API along with Spinnaker's
imperative workflow engine to
orchestrate deployments so that we can
manage our infrastructure as a
ubiquitous experience for our developers
right and so as part of that we're
moving our developers up the stack we're
getting them up off of those
infrastructure api's so that our
infrastructure teams can innovate and
move fast and do the things that they
need to do in order to make the
infrastructure better without impacting
the application developers I recently
had a meeting with one of our with one
of our big development groups and and
the director there was explaining that
his team is now accounting an actual
number of what they refer to as the tech
tax on their team and this tech tax is
is the time that they're losing building
business value because infrastructure
teams keep coming and asking them to
migrate or do new things by XYZ date for
a BC reason right and and that's really
what we want to get rid of right we need
to stop doing that as an infrastructure
organization or as platform developers
we need to allow app developers to focus
on building business value and stop
worrying about the infrastructure so we
want to reduce that cognitive load that
write once run anywhere
I shouldn't have to change my
application in order to move it from a
container based runtime to a VM based
runtime I need to make sure that my
workloads are deploying consistently
regardless of where they are
infrastructure and I need my
infrastructure teams to be able to do
their job by upgrading clusters or
innovating new technologies and building
things that can that can span across the
entire enterprise so in order to support
this we've decided to take what we
learned from you know matrix and extend
it to all of target's infrastructure so
we settled on saying all infrastructure
our target when it comes to runtime
deployments or or workload or workload
deployment and running has to be managed
via the kubernetes api so we talked
about all workloads on tap as though
there are replicas set and a pod
regardless of if it's on a kubernetes
cluster or not right so we write we
write layers that that interface with
things like OpenStack and then present a
communities compliant API on top of it
this gives us this gives us a single
unified experience across all of our
infrastructure it also allows us then to
deploy type of intelligent routing layer
on top of that infrastructure that's
spinnaker talks you to do deployments
now that int that routing layer that
intelligence engine can can consume data
from wherever we wanted to in order to
make workload placement decisions about
your application it also allows us to do
things like if we want to upgrade a
kubernetes cluster that requires an
outage we can just bring up a new
kubernetes cluster disable the old one
the existing workloads will continue
running and all new deployments will go
to the new cluster right so in order to
make this work if we're gonna use the
kubernetes api everywhere we have to
model a concept of what an application
is so that it works across all of these
things right so we have to talk about
what we're gonna deploy and since the
secure Burnette ease we're gonna be
deploying docker containers so
application developers had target on tap
during their CI process build and
publish a docker container and that's
the end of the story they'll never have
to change that they'll never have to do
anything different they just need to
tell us what how much CPU and memory
they want they need to tell us what
network port they're gonna accept
traffic on they need to tell us how do
they want their application to roll out
right what should we do with the old
version how many replicas
we run and finally they need to tell us
how do we know that your application is
healthy at any given time right
those are fundamentally the core
concepts of knowing of up an application
so how do if everything's a docker
container and that's what our developers
are building how do we do things like
run on OpenStack well our layer that
sits in front of OpenStack then when it
receives a deployment command as a
replica set can call out to our
enterprise bakery which is actually one
of the subcomponents of spinnaker that
we've just extracted and are running
standalone without the rest of spinnaker
and so we do a just-in-time bake of a VM
image of that docker container so we
translate that docker container into a
VM deployment and then tells OpenStack
to go run that so we were able to use
all of Spinnaker's built-in abilities
for modeling container based deployments
we can use triggering and we can do all
the the stuff that we'd want to do but
we can extend it across any
infrastructure that we want to bring in
and tomorrow when we you know when one
of my developers says hey we want to use
nomad or something we can plug Nomad
into this system with very little effort
and and not impact our application
developers so we could start testing
workload deployments on there if we
wanted to we also have to provide a
consistent set of runtime primitives to
our applications right if we're if we
were running on kubernetes and our
developers we're using config maps and
secrets and services and all that stuff
via cluster they'd be locked into the
kubernetes ecosystem and they wouldn't
be able to run on something like a like
an OpenStack if they needed to so we
can't we couldn't do that so we run all
of those primitives outside of the
cluster based workloads with things like
hashey core console and bolts we use a
global Fabio load balancing layer for
this and all of our workloads that
deployed that are deployed regardless of
where it is in the infrastructure gets a
routable IP address for this safe for
this sake so we're not doing any network
over life we also provide primitives for
logs and metrics and like kind of API
proxying things so that we can reason
about applications in a very consistent
manner and this allows us to do kind of
sre and
support operations across all the
applications on tab very readily without
having to know specifics about that
application and finally I mentioned
before when we started playing with
spinnaker we noticed that a lot of our
developers don't use all the
capabilities of like a complex work you
know complex pipeline of any kind and
since we've distilled this model of what
a what an application or a deployment is
down to these kind of core concepts we
can also kind of encode a best practice
of how we're going to roll out an
application into our infrastructure and
we can do that synthetically in a way
that spinnaker doesn't need to know the
fully materialized pipeline we can
generate it for them based on what
they're telling us about the application
so we've we've written a new application
that exists as part of our spinnaker
installation spinnaker has a component
called front 50 it's responsible for
storing your pipeline metadata so we
wrote an application called back forty
and and it synthetically generates
pipeline information based on
application metadata it also allows us
to if we need to inject in a fully
materialized pipeline for spinnaker so
if we if we need to build some type of
complex workflow we can do that right
this allows us to kind of manage best
practices for deployments across the
whole across the whole enterprise
without having to go to developers and
ask them to
hey go modify these pipelines right so
that so that is that is kind of the
target of the future of where we're
going right and it's been a long journey
to get there right long in a sense but
in the last five years we've tried a lot
of different things right we've
experimented with a lot of tools and
patterns we've learned a lot about what
our developers want to do or and what
they really need to do and we fine-tuned
what we treat as a as an application or
a deployment or workload at target so
that we can reason about the scale a lot
easier so before I go just my final
thoughts on all of this if you're not
doing immutable infrastructure yet you
should probably start
it gives you a real solid foundation for
building consistent deployment and
operand operations patterns for your
organization and spinnaker really will
help you drive a that type of adoption
if you aren't doing it yet and it
provides many of the best practices so
you don't need to create them yourself
if you're building a platform for
yourself or if you're looking to
customize these tools don't be afraid to
shape your usage with flexible opinions
your developers are always going to ask
for all the things but managing scale is
a lot easier when you have opinionated
patterns of how your developers can use
those tools right and spinnaker will
help you model a lot of those cloud
providers in a consistent set of
primitives and how we're going to talk
about an application or how we're gonna
talk about a deployment and finally
don't be afraid to customize right this
is really the power of why we win from
you know big conjoined applications into
into micro services right that can do
that are responsible for singular things
right using open source tooling gives
you a lot of productivity but don't be
afraid to customize that that tooling
for your specific needs if it makes
sense to right and in this case
Spinnaker's Spinnaker's design and
architecture will allow you to give you
a default installation out of the box
with all the goodness but then you can
you can you know piecemeal things if you
need to or take them and run them
completely on their own in a standalone
environment so I hope I hope what I was
talking about today was interesting to
you I hope you have the great rest of
the conference and thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]